Now you might be thinking,
why are we writing the code to display
a GIF if we haven't converted
the video to a GIF yet?
The answer is,
it's easier to test the GIF conversion
code if we can see the GIF.
A UI image view off the shelf doesn't
have the ability to display a GIF.
Let's see how the gif was displayed
in the Objective-C project.
If we go into the WelcomeViewController
and look in the viewWillAppear method,
we can see where this variable
firstLaunchGif is being initialized.
If we Cmd+click on this
initWithName method,
it'll take us inside the gif class.
Here we can see that the image is
being set with a call to this method
animatedImageWithAnimatedGifName.
Okay, where's this method?
Let's see, if we scroll up we can see
tat animatedImageWithAnimatedGifName
is a part of this extension
that Rob Mayoff wrote,
that UIImage+animatedGIF extension.
This seems like it's getting
a little complicated.
But guess what?
Arne Bahlo has an extension that
does exactly what we need and
it's written in Swift.
So let's switch back to our
Swift project and go ahead and
add a new file called UIImage+gif.
You can find a link to
the GitHub repo containing
Bahlo's SwiftGif extension
in the corresponding text.
If we go into his repository and
we go into the SwiftGif common folder,
we can see this UIImage+Gif.swift file.
Go ahead and copy this code and put
it into the Swift file you just made.
Make sure that you copy this
copyright information as well, so
that Bahlo gets proper credit.
Next we want to hook up
the storyboard outlet for
our WelcomeViewController's
gifImageView.
So let's open up the storyboard and
we'll open up the assistant editor.
And we'll hook up the GIFImageView.
Next we want to set the GIFImageView
here in viewWillAppear.
If we go back to GitHub can see
here in our Arne Bahlo's readme for
the UI image extension
how to use the extension.
I'm going to call this
proofOfConceptGif for now.
And then we'll call UIImage, and
then the method gifWithName, and
then you'll notice that I've
included a couple GIFs to get
you guys started in the project.
hotlineBling is the name of one of them,
and then we need to set
the image on our gifImageView
to be the proofOfConceptGif.
And of course we don't want
to forget to call super.
So we'll make sure to
call superViewWillAppear.
And now we should be ready to run it.
And when we run it,
sweet, there's Drake.
Now when we convert our video into
a GIF, we'll be able to display it.